many of the victims of February's
earthquakes that hit Southern turkey and
Northern Syria were children those who
survived still live the tragedy Muhammad
Abdullah is from the Syrian Village of
einshara he lost his parents and other
members of his family he also lost his
hand this young boy's life has turned
upside down
um
madarchy
also lost his parents he's now living
with his uncle's family
the natural disaster has had an
emotional toll on children in the
opposition Enclave in Northwest Syria
some of them have still not healed from
living through War
now they say they need to heal from a
different kind of experience Fahad says
he can't forget his father's last words
foreign
the United Nations has more than 3.7
million children across Syria have been
affected by the quakes
and it says many will need psychological
support they've lost any sense of safety
while many others are displaced yet
again and there are those who find
themselves alone here
[Music]
that's because Muhammad lost many of his
friends in the earthquakes